good to see you oh i just shocked you
you're so full of energy that electric
energy electric energy leather
this moment with the cutouts the cutouts
hello won't he do it it's sin city
and you are here to play i am just a
little peek our allure cover star too
you liked it yes i love it i love that
it was very like natural and different
i loved it and powerful always you
talked about your debut album which is
on the horizon your solo debut album you
talked about how you've been
in a lost place and music has brought
you out of it to be the woman you are
today how would you describe the woman
you are right now i am growing every day
but i'm finding my strength little by
little and something my god mom always
says she's like i'm a little caterpillar
and i'm finally bursting out of my
cocoon and being a big bright butterfly
and people are seeing my wings and i'm
seeing that i have wings for the first
time
yeah what a beautiful
moment it is and i'm so happy to be here
with you now i feel like i asked you
this a lot
do you guys have a date for the new
album yet i don't have a date yeah gotta
ask my label but you know just work in
and keep perfecting it and i'm really
proud of it for sure good things take
time they say always but it's so special
right now so i just can't wait when the
right time will be you said you're
perfecting it how are you when you have
all the tracks listed out and you're
going through them at some point you
have to say okay i'm giving it to god
this is this is already amazing yeah
definitely that's me right now i think
in any creative process in the beginning
you're like oh this sucks and then
you're like i love it and now i'm in the
process where i'm doubting it all over
again but i know it's so special like
i'm not the type of person who'll listen
to my music constantly so i'll step away
even for a week and i just listened to
the full checklist from top to bottom
the other day and i kind of shocked
myself i was like oh i really love this
so just getting mixing right and
everything and i can't wait to stop
talking about it for people to just
press play same yeah yeah yeah when the
time comes i hope we get to chat with
you congratulations and enjoy the night
thank you so much you look gorgeous as
always you look like a golden trophy
we're you know we're quite the duo right
here with the gold i love it
i'm falling over in these heels oh don't
fall i got you everything oh do you mind
if we do a photo oh yes the hair too oh
wait i'm having you just do a little
twirl i love it
um
[Music]
you